okay this is a really quick proof which
we can do by mathematical induction so
long as you understand how inequalities
work when you're trying to manipulate
them okay so this is what I've been
asked to prove that M Squared is greater
than equal to n for n being positive
integers okay so one two three four five
six seven and so on okay so I prove by
induction it always starts by testing
the first allowable value okay so I'm
going to test N equals one so on the
left hand side I've got one square which
is 1 on the right hand side I've got 1
and sure enough the left-hand side is
greater than or equal to the right hand
side okay therefore it's true for that
first value okay next we want to assume
that the statement is true for some
value okay so it's true for N equals n
let's let's make it K where K follows
the same rules that n follows namely
it's positive integer okay so what does
that look like well it looks like this
the K squared is greater than K I'm just
substituted okay now on the basis of
that assumption what I want to do is
prove that it's true for the next
allowable value okay
namely K plus 1 what happens when you
substitute all that in this is what
you're going to have okay so this here
this is what I'm required to prove how
do I do it whatever the start is what
I'm going to do is start with my
assumption here and then I'm going to
try and do what I need to to twist and
turn it so I can arrived at what I'm
trying to prove okay so I'm going to say
by assumption okay K squared is greater
than or equal to K okay so far so good
well let's do some valid things that if
I can just add 1 to both sides now the
reason why that's useful is because now
I have the right-hand side looking
exactly how I want it so I don't need to
muck around with that
more now what can I do here well um if I
got K squared plus one right since K is
positive I can say well K squared plus
two K plus 1 right um if K is positive
this thing what's your bigger than that
right it's got to be bigger than that
because it's it's the same thing but
I've added something on to it okay but I
know that is greater than equal to K
plus 1 okay so therefore you know I can
actually eliminate this guy in the
middle here if this is bigger than this
is being amount and surely this must be
much bigger than this right so I could
say therefore K squared plus 2k plus 1
is greater than or equal to K plus 1 now
that's the crucial step okay it seems to
be funny you know you add this out of
nowhere why do I add it out of nowhere
what it lets me do is it lets me
factorize because K square plus 2k plus
1 is K plus 1 or squared right which is
greater than or equal to K plus 1 and
that's what I am trying to prove namely
that is true for N equals k plus 1 okay
so I can say since the statement is true
for the first allowable value namely N
equals 1 it must also be true for all
the rest of them N equals 2 3 4 and so
on
namely all of the values where N is a
positive integer and that's the proof